[Musique]
je serai dans l'équipe le natif quel que
soit le jeu dès qu'il ya d'autres gens
qui jouent en même temps que moi je
perds de toute façon on va aller en
finale et je vais gagner confié bonjour
bienvenue sur le quiz internet le
deuxième quiz que je fais de ce genre là
et on va tester la culture internet des
gens qui sont autour de cette table
inial à gagner un magnifique trophée le
quiz internet trophée dû grand gagnant
de ce quiz
parce qu'ils avaient tout donné enfin
donc sur vous nous avons à ma gauche on
the panda plaisir eh oui si vous pensez
merci des plats c'est la team msn ce pas
à notre droite nous avons là tout
justement la team caramail bien
évidemment nous allons commencer avec
des démos des mises d'accord vous
n'écoutez pas on va commencer avec le
pré roll on va comme ça il décline son
caramel
lequel de ces sites de rencontres
n'existe pas du love un site de
rencontre pour les fans de john front
rencontre ainsi deux rencontres pour
militants fn crise au mythe un site de
rencontres pour trisomique glut m
ainsi deux rangs pour intolérants au
gluten alors les omis s'ils existent
vraiment jul l'assam et américaines
pourquoi pas 6dans rencontre ça veut
dire 18 ans logiquement oui les fans de
john mais au final c'est un peu
rencontrons militants fn ça n'attendrait
pas comme je suis sûr qu'après tous les
autres partis politiques bon ba ba pour
votre joue d'ailleurs à l'origine c'est
le premier point pour un team car il
n'existe pas attention ce mécène trump
n'a jamais tweeté le réchauffement
climatique a été inventé par les chinois
robert pattinson ne devrait pas se
remettre avec kristen stewart il neige à
new york
on veut le réchauffement climatique mon
mur sera un succès toi on va nous copier
le réchauffement climatique l'un des
partenaires il l'a fait le mont mur sera
un succès tout le monde a vu le copier
je crois qu'il l'a fait aussi mais le
truc c'est et les basques en fait il là
on se rend compte de la 3 qui existe non
mais c'est là on sent qu'on en fait les
cas qu'il aurait pu les tweets et il
serait pas du genre à demander le
réchauffement climatique l'année ce
n'est pas une demande c'est jean image à
new york que ben alors le réchauffement
climatique on a tant fait une belle
imitation
merci non mais si vous coûteront bout le
coup de robert pattinson il l'a
forcément tweeté la force et heymans est
possible parce qu'il a déjà twitté les
trucs sur sur les fourmis russe tripy la
fin politique est magnifique wen an qui
là je suis sûr qu'il a tweeté un truc
sur robert pattinson était sur ou juste
tu es confiant
dt par contre comme moi je suis partant
sur pattinson et stewart
moi je pense que c'est une erreur et
qu'il faut dire il neige à new york en
gaule réchauffement qui menace tu sais
quoi
igo new york ils nagent à new york on
veut le réchauffement climatique je suis
obligé de vie commun et n'a jamais dit
mon mur sur un succès toujours à nous
copier
il a dit les trois autres écumant il
n'était pas content que robert pattinson
se remette avec kristen stewart
il a dit sur twitter je rappelle que
nous leur dire du tout et 2 3 minutes
s'te plaît
laquelle de ces histoire est fausse un
sdf a trouvé un travail grâce à twitter
elle accouche dans un hubert et nomme
son fils hubert se marie avec son hôte
airbnb elle retrouve sa mère grâce à
facebook oui ça me semble avoir entendu
parler alors c'était dans un taxi parce
que j'aime l'info supplémentaires il
nomme son fils hubert tuchan pousse dans
l'oeuf après que le sdf j'y crois ou
parce que même en france j'avais vu ça
il ya un sdf qu'on sait qui twitte
souvent des trucs scénariste sauvette eh
bien ça peut arriver ça devait arriver
saint louis il rencontre quand tu
n'ouvres truc ce serait si passer un
exam beaucoup plus de temps que nous il
se marie avec son hôte airbnb n'existe
pas mais aussi ça doit exister n'était
pas au courant [ __ ] désolé résister
mais il ya plein air bien de l'enfant
attention la question image est pour
vous lequel de ces logos google n'existe
pas ça le fond ce n'est plus ce qu'elle
est que moi poursuit la hat est comme ça
toi je vais te laisser sous jacente
c'est bon je balance le premier avec les
de l image choc
ça veut pas ça veut rien dire ensuite le
troisième avec tous les os je pense que
cela peut être une fin pas ce qui se
passe c'est que c'est dans les résultats
de recherche on a plein de haut était en
fait c'est l'axé la couleur du deuxième
haut qui me gêne c'est pas du tout dans
la charte google là où il ya 8000 au
mois c'est la grenouille des yeux
globalement comment fait on fait au pif
ont fait parce que la vue pour moi moi
j'aime aucun des quatre voilà je vois
les opérateurs et globalement le google
avec deux mois et moi une moindre choc
se teintant les onze ans google a dû
arriver
moi je partirai sur les deux ailes les
deux elles touchent chaque mois hu est
allé partout sur les deux ailes
s'arrêter sapin ouais c'est les
multiples aux qui ne sont pas dans la
charte graphique effectivement c'est la
fin de la manche quand même un peu dire
il ya eu au team et mécène team kara
s'il vous plaît on arrive à la nouvelle
manche c'est une épreuve de rapidité
voilà sur le buzzer attention bien sûr
va falloir te découvrir d'où viennent
les sons le fonds va se lancer et avoir
deviné d'accord premiers sont assez
l'ouverture de fixe au ses conseillers
je vais refaire la bouche bombo son
numéro deux matches at le filtre chiens
et wii pikmin au troisième soit celle
des fab' essonne louise c'est le risque
c'est le rire après ce maxi group et
louise 2 ms msn windows live messenger
msn c'est le premier truc de base est
bonne on sait plus et même jeté par
sneijder son suivant ça sent le message
haïti ku oui c'est plus un truc que
j'aime si tu sais pas c'était les
problèmes premier messenger c'était
l'époque avant à 20 les scènes d'époque
hellénistique you yahoo messenger
nouveau son s'il vous plaît oui c'était
je viens encore de points mais attention
je pense et ça nous arrive servir à quoi
un peu [ __ ] de me passer sont là
maintenant je suis énervé on voit qu'ils
ne paient pas l'antivirus attention aux
noms sa boutique à un modem sont ou bien
tu un modem 56k
tout à fait
c'est chiant et dure vingt secondes or
là on l'a coupée et un dernier attention
sncf c'est pas du tout allait bien je
demande un arbitrage c'est pas du tout
un territoire
on arrive sur une nouvelle épreuve de
rapidité je vous donne le nom d'un site
anglais américains il faut trouver la
version française
on va juste dire point fr non exemple
ebay leboncoin facebook copains d'avant
on y attend les connaît bien un mur et
tout mais c'est juste on trouve les
copains d'avant
chatroulette bazooka oui très dur
attention youtube wat tv kto si myspace
twitter myspace
oui
ouais si facile attention je dis paille
with weezi on a le bonheur on leur donne
le point attention il est compliqué
j'aime beaucoup cela google maps api sur
les jeunes jouera pas sur un petit
dernier brazzers pour jacky michel oui
je sais pas si j'ai honte ou si je suis
fier je connais très bien mais si ça
passe français qui sont globalement les
mêmes que des américains blancs moins
bien
oui ce sont bien ces succès la
définition et on peut applaudir l'équipe
gagnante est illégal
non je pensais me disent de moi ça va
vous dire ce qu'on est venu les mains
vides
on part comme ça ça va ça va ça va ça
fait sens on sent la rancoeur on est
juste l'équipe qui passent moins de
temps sur chaque image
l'étudiant plus vite si mal de finale je
vois ce que tu t'en veux quand même en
finale à peu près alors là c'est des
questions des questions sur un petit peu
tout internet plein de choses d'accord
voulait faire un petit chiffon me pour
savoir qui a gagné à lyon qui va
commencer
bah je suis pas là pour gagner de toute
façon quand c'est quelqu'un pour
participer tous les smartphones et wim
allez allez c'est parti
un nul pourrait prendre au maximum ou de
questions top avant de faire de la vod
que faisait m fixe meetic est créée par
des français est vrai pour pourquoi pas
oh oui comment s'appelle logiciel qui
permet de bloquer les pubs sur internet
ben ca à deux blocs
oui michel drucker un blog pourquoi pas
oui oui il a free il a tout compris oui
j'ai co comment on dit buzz selon
l'académie française le mannequin
challenge servait à lever des fonds pour
assurer aux faux oui qu'est le service
créé par tim duncan
je ne sais pas meilleure claude quel
site propose de diffuser ces parties de
jeux vidéo en ligne
c'est le de tout de tout oui qui a été
le précédent nom d'orange
clémentine lâcher la chanson du la
chanson du voilà voilà
et l'animal sur le logo firefox c'est un
petit bonheur oui
et c'est mam a finalement jeté
je les avais tout c'est vraiment de quoi
la chanson du dimanche
la chanson du dimanche adacore wanadoo
avant c'est une dot com qui est créé et
megaupload selon l'académie française
faut dire ramdam est totalement financée
par nicole ploteau dégâts nous avons six
points puis on a tous est ce que tu peux
faire mais maxence ou peut-être
peut-être
attention ce mouvement top le service de
musique créée par jay-z et kanye west
tidal a service pour se filmer en
faisant du playback semoule ou non je me
manque a dit mme royal
comment us command ichat et au québec
parler comment s'appellent les lunettes
de snapshot aucune idée instagram
appartient à google vrai ou faux faux
selon l'inventeur du format on dit gif
tiff gif wyss nachat appartient à
facebook ou vrai ou faux faux oui quelle
école a fait mardi keerbergen oui ouais
et effet le seul fils le plus connu du
monde où g aux oscars oui avant les
choeurs de twitter étaient des étoiles
oui la star la plus suivis au monde sur
instagram
je ne sais pas comment s'appelle le film
sur la création de facebook social
network un vine durée maximum 5 secondes
il faut qu'elle est symbole de lycos je
me sers y moment s'appelle l'école créée
par xavier niel
je ne sais plus le site d' images gore
où on allait quand les cadeaux quand eux
elle est déterminée world bon je pense
que j'ai gagné a n'ont pas beaucoup ses
spectacles
les lunettes de snapshots et s'est dit
désolé le doute sur mais c'est quand
même
non non c'est que en fait j'avais un
filtre en fait je vais pas tu te
commande ichat et au québec
chacun ses camardes et si tu télécharges
skype
il ya des chances que ça disent qu'avoir
des bigots symbole de lycos était
conscient mais chercher les causes un
bon chien c'est selena gomez qui est
suivi sur ses pas sur un stadium
j'allais dire c'est une mauvaise mais je
pense que c'est sur un store ce que j'ai
dit tu as gagné c'est pas la séance n'a
pas peur de nous [ __ ] j'avais compris
jamais compris eh bien on peut applaudir
[Applaudissements]
alors à puteaux avait nommément j'ai
joué ma ville
le voilà où des baux est vraiment beau
c'est un petit l'étagère ça vous a plu
et franchement je tenais à fait si on
félicité suspect faire un discours
totalement les autres candidats qui
n'ont pas démérité
merci beaucoup à ça d'avoir gagné déjà
d'avoir participé merci d'avoir gagné
maintenant c'est quoi ça fait trop
plaisir nous avoir autour de cette table
et j'espère que l'on se retrouve être
l'émission attack n'hésitez pas à
regarder ces chaînes youtube incroyable
moi je vous dis à très vite
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner car vous
n'êtes pas si nombreux à bientôt
[Musique]
je suis très content très très content
je tenais embrasser toutes les équipes
toutes les personnes qui m'ont soutenu
qui ont que moi c'est vraiment grâce à
moi c'était qui paraît vente parce qu'il
a permis de rebondir sur mon succès et
de gagner
totalement fou